ce soir on voulait avoir votre
témoignage parce que c'est vrai que le
procès s'est ouvert et jean-luc d'abord
déjà que faisiez-vous vos moments où
coulibaly est entré dans l'hyper cacher
j'étais dans le meuble frais j'étais en
train de ranger la charcuterie la corse
quand visuellement vous êtes vous
habiller ou travailler là bas où elle
travaille l'ama donc vous entendez
changer si je vois d'un coup une
personne qui entrent comme ça et puis
tout le monde s'affole tout une crise
donc on sait chacun éparpillés chacun
chaque achat mapa j'ai tout de suite
compris ce qui se passait au pas du tout
eu franchement franchement non mais j'ai
entendu les cris la fois le mans je ne
pensais pas que c'était cinq mois
c'était dur
vous avez croisé le le le regarde de
coulibaly bien sûr dans quelles
circonstances vous êtes vous êtes monté
vous étiez vous étiez en bas de magasins
il était en moi j'étais marot d'accord
puis je me suis caché au fond du magasin
je me suis mis par terre je me suis
cachée j'ai été à mon téléphone je suis
resté sur le son du carrelage aux mavs
aux meubles du frais à côté du mode
d'alcool enfin tous vous êtes caché où
vous êtes caché son soutien par terre je
me suis mis par terre j'ai fait le mort
adacore et vous a parlé oui c'est comme
je suis je me suis levé donc j'ai jeu
quand j'ai entendu j'ai entendu des
coups de feu j'ai entendu les cris d
affolement les tout j'ai entendu j'ai
entendu que c'était horrible quoi et je
suis sorti je pouvais pas rester là
parce que j'étais vraiment à découvert
olive j'étais caché comme ça par terre
geci rente il va me voir il va me tuer
je suis sorti j'ai attendu un bon quart
d'heure vingt minutes j'étais par terre
a bougé je suis parti j'ai été vers lui
ça a été un livre inédit quoi je hume et
demi ma vie mais toi tu étais où j'ai
dit j'étais caché au fond du magasin il
ya personne d'autre avec toi tu n'y a
personne
je vais regarder dans les yeux c'est
vrai qu'il avait un regard un peu un
regard un peu comme on dirait
qu'il était là pour bien faire une chose
quoi c'était été déterminée ils étaient
déterminés et donc là il vous dit pas
oui mais toi tu t'es oui la personne
n'oserait histoire m'a dit tu fais quoi
je dis je travaille dans le mc stradale
magasin je me suis caché au fond moi je
me suis assis avec les autres tout on
était sur un seul endroit je me suis mis
avec les autres pour l'instant vous avez
tout de suite compris qu'il s'agissait
d'un terroriste oui quand j'ai vu
comment il était sur les coups de feu et
j'ai découvert les morts parce que
j'avais je n'avais pas vu ça
j'étais comme j'étais cache en fait je
n'avais pas vu il avait l'air stressé
oui oui savait qui était qui était
encore bien faire une chose une alerte
reste aux yeux quand je les regarde et
j'étais face à lui à plusieurs reprises
vous n'avez pas eu peur aussi parce que
même de retourner là bas avec les autres
vous n'êtes pas lisse et si tu te j'ai
eu très peur très peur très peur ça m'a
touchée ça va j'ai dit je fais ça je
suis obligé je peux pas rester là je
peux pas rester cachés j'étais pas
j'étais à découvert ont dit que j'étais
tout seul mais les chansons parce que si
c'est vrai que vous aviez peur qui
viennent voilà que vous avez préféré
être avec les années que je sois une
montre que je suis là quoi je sais pas
que je cachais info quand une cache et
autrement mais bon je pouvais pas rester
là à quoi c'était pas possible c'est pas
si vous a demandé de faire des choses
pour lui oui j avoue qu à vous à moi il
m'a pris pour faire ces choses que j med
a demandé d'enlever les caméras
barricadé la porte
descendre au sous sol j'ai même à
plusieurs reprises je suis descendu deux
trois fois au sous sol pour aller aux
toilettes j'avais jamais vu d'abord
j'avais envie de toi est quoi ai-je et
il m'a dit à plusieurs reprises était
une fois deux fois trois fois une femme
est ce qui se passe était malade sinon
je prends des médicaments avait attesté
pas ça je descends du parce que j'ai la
douleur de le stress a bien sûr bon
j'avais bouger mois mais ils vont parler
jeu là quand vous décrivez c'est vrai
que c'est bizarre
terry qui brille vous parlez comme si
vous connaissiez depuis longtemps il a
eu un jeu il vous parlez de manière
normale de manière détendue
ces bains
je parle de ça parce que j'avais peur
chercheurs ce qui me disaient de faire
j'étais obligée de le faire je le
faisais je vais vous donner des evaux
n'était c'était soit la manière d'or où
il était plutôt voilà avec vous ils vous
disaient tu va m'aider a barricadé la
porte ou de la faire il faisait
bizarrement oui c'est vrai je fais la
moindre erreur ou chez ses il m'aurait
tué c'est sûr et certain il vous l'a dit
ça ouais magma a menacé à plusieurs
reprises j'ai eu vent que j'ai menti
plusieurs fois j'ai manqué la meilleure
des quelques couacs au mensonge
ben j'ai déjà enlevé les caméras j'en ai
laissé une qui était dans le béton j'ai
pas pu l'enlever avec canal clients du
magasin c'était trop et puis elle était
entrée dans le béton donc il est rentré
dans son bureau et puis il m'a dit mais
déjà déjà établi une caméra servant j'ai
fait exprès de l'année c'est donc on
était une télésurveillance qu'ont été
vus jusqu'à 3h15 3 en vain ils ont ils
ont ils ont dû tout ce qui se passait en
laissant cette caméra ça a permis de
voir ce qui se passe parce que c'est sa
part le service de surveillance et est
donc qu'est-ce qui vous a dit qu'il ya
une caméra puis un produit trop parti
avec eux
vous avez dit richard et plus ouvrir les
pages où je ne savais pas je vais
oublier dans l'eau et où j'étais obligé
de justifier quoi j'ai menti à plusieurs
reprises y avait pas que ça vous avez
imaginé un instant pouvoir vous en
sortir vivant ou ou pas du tout
franchement non je pensais pas que
j'allais bien sortir j'avais un j'avais
avec tout ce que j'ai vu quand j'ai
découvert les gens qui étaient par terre
sanglante et les trois personnes enfin
au début avec deux personnes neuf ans
les caisses un petit yoann qui agonise
et dans les deux les deux pères de
famille avec leurs enfants aussi leurs
parterres j'aurais vu ça j'étais sama ça
m'a fait vraiment vraiment réfléchir ici
on va pas s'en sortir cette histoire
j'avais je pensais je regardais de leur
camp l'acquéreur ça va se terminer à
quel ans à la finir langouët ce jeudi je
veux pas pouvoir aller en israël
assister au mariage de mon fils et au
mois d'août on a pu
j'avais tout réservé il ya plein de
choses qu'il y avait plein de choses qui
m'est revenue j'ai dit ça y est c'est
fini c'est à essayer de vous accrocher à
quelque chose à un espoir pas de famille
ni votre peut-être voilà votre fils
comme vous dites qu'ils allaient se
marier vous avez essayé de un moment de
vous dire je vais essayer de m'évader
d'essayer de penser quelque chose de
positif ou peut-être me dire j'ai laissé
le dire et j'espère j'espère qu'on va
s'en sortir j'avais très peur et jésus
j'ai pas j'suis pas compris mais j'ai
menti à plusieurs reprises quand vous ai
dit que j'ai dit il faut que je m'en
sorte faut qu'on s'en sorte mais je
regarde l'heure tout le temps je parlais
avec les autres comme en potage vous
parler avec les autres tâches ou pas du
tout oui je parle de crise outre leur
disais pas ça fait peur regardent ils
diront disait le petit long train
d'agoniser ils peuvent rien faire il
agonise et agonise et la nausée johan qu
elle et on peut rien faire et on a
demandé de le faire sortir il n'a pas
voulu ils ont pas voulu
il n'a pas voulu lui avait demandé vous
l'avait dit l'une ses ressorts il faut
sortir et d'entrain agonise il avait
reçu une balle d'essai retrouver rassure
il était parti n'était pas allonger à
six a coûté 5 à 10 il agonise et tout le
monde voyait sa tournée quand vous lui
avez demandé de sortir il a dit quoi il
a dit non on ne peut pas sortir voulait
qu'on l'abatte il a dit comme ça voulait
pour l'abattre ladino chez nous on
appelle nous avait le respect du de
l'être humain on a va on n'abat pas
laisser sortir d'un souffert il a
souffert son fer puis s'éteint alors
aujourd'hui enfin si cécile procès qui
c'est qui s'est ouvert cette semaine
pourquoi n'es tu pas les témoigner aussi
parce que j'ai pensé
j'avais peur j'avais peur ça me rappelle
l'agent parr ne chante pas encore vous
passez la normale de raconter mon
histoire je suis en train de penser à ça
à ce petit de 20 en août chanson you and
on pense tous à lui tous les jours
vraiment et de toutes les victimes
d'ailleurs les pertuis là j'ai vu de
certains de mes collègues
enfin les ceux qui travaillent et moraux
témoigner comme ça j'ai dit peut-être
maintenant j'ai envie de changer d'avis
il faut que je raconte ce qui s'est
passé je sais pas je pense aller
normalement et j'ai pas voulu dévoiler
plate y aller maintenant
oui parce que je me dis ça il faut que
les gens sachent la vérité que vraiment
ce qui s'est passé parce qu'on a tous
une version différente
il m'a demandé plein de choses de faire
ceci de faire cela je l'écouté gt gt
l'âge je raconter n'importe quoi j'ai
sortir une demande de descendre au
sous-sol de chercher les otages
je vois les otages qui s'enferme dans sa
chambre fois que je parle avec eux dit
nous on va j'ai fait monter deux
personnes je me suis fait remonter
l'adjoint du magasin et un client j'ai
fait de monter de personne à personne
avec qui j'étais je travaille la
caissière a fait monter plusieurs
personnes aussi donc quand vous devez
vous disais qu'est ce qui se passait en
bas où il dit rien il avait rien qui se
passe en a alors qu'est ce qu'il a fait
il a ouvert la porte il a regardé comme
ça il a vu que je mentais il a senti
levante et j'ai dit qu'il y avait
personne n'a appuyé après bien sûr on a
eu la la bande d'arrêt quand bfm a dit
que les otages étaient enfermés en va là
il m'a regardé encore une fois j'ai
menti j'ai menti monde est content de ça
ça c'est vraiment ça c'est un vrai sujet
c'est incroyable parce que non sma votre
place là et là tous les téléspectateurs
doivent se mettre à votre place et se
dire la course à l'information
c'est quand même mon nikon coulibaly a a
compris et a appris qu'il y avait des
otages hambach que vous aviez montée et
dans ce cas il avait la gagne et dans
les yeux il m'a laissé c'est incroyable
ça ça cesse et il m'a dit barricadé la
porte il a entendu votre collègue sortir
il a entendu il m'a il m'a appelé et m'a
dit et un c'est quoi cette porte là je
laisse ça c'est l'émoi de charge et ça
c'est la porte aussi vous ouvrira pas
vous êtes de rang c'est le parking
derrière le enfin l'hyper cacher
donc moi il me le dira m la barre en fer
parce qu'elle était par terre j'ai remis
la barre en fer il m'a dit prends moi la
palette de farine mais le mois devant la
porte félin barriques d'une barricade
trois mois les tons fait tout ce qu'il
fallait pour barricadé la porte
il m'a dit de faire ça et un gorille qui
l'a vu que vous aviez menti sur les
otages à cause du brouillard avec sa
mère comme ceux qui voulaient juste
senti que j'avais peur senti qu'il avait
un rôle à part vous menacez vous dit non
mais marc il m'a dit il a ouvert la
porte si là il m'a pas il n'a pas eu
confiance en moi
il a ouvert la porte il va regarder les
escaliers parce qu'il ya sous sol il a
ouvert la porte et puis il a fait ça
comme il était tout seul ne pouvait pas
décemment et juste fait ce que vous et
vous
et jamais venu à l'esprit jean-luc de
rester en bas avec les donnons jamais
vous êtes dit je vais remonter quoi ce
qu'il m'a dit descendre il m'avait dit
de descendre pour chercher les gens qui
étaient en bas il ya un an vous êtes
jeune et je vais me barricader en bas
aussi avec eux non non non je suis monté
j'ai fait monter deux paires salim ali
fonctionnement des personnes j'étais
obligé de dire aux gens il faut que vous
montiez parce qu'il veut tuer tout le
monde
j'étais menti encore une fois pour les
faire monter parce que si je serai
monter sans personne il aurait dit alors
ils m'ont dit tu il ya un truc qui va
pas j'ai fait monter deux personnes une
personne qui a fait monter plusieurs
personnes d'acier et une personne qui
était caché que j'ai pas bu puis aux
avatars qui a été tué il a pris là mais
ils doivent bien sûr et voilà j'avais
vraiment vraiment j'ai dans la société
j'ai eu plusieurs braquages
je n'ai pas eu peur comme cette fois ci
j'ai trois braquages à main armée déjà
avant et là bon là c'est autre chose
c'est autre chose c'est le terroriste
c'est autre chose jean-luc qu'est ce qui
a changé dans votre quotidien depuis on
vous sent traumatisé encore oui je suis
toujours sur mes gardes
je suis pensif je dors toujours un peu
moins j'ai arrêté mes antidépresseurs
j'ai fait beaucoup j'ai fait du sport
après un an et demi et deux ans que j'ai
commencé à faire un peu de sport
ça m'a aidé à évacuer en salle sports de
combat egea grâce à ça j'ai réussi à
enlever cet été voir un psychologue 6,4
gt suivi j'ai pris je pas voulu rentrer
dans le dos dans les antidépresseurs
j'ai toujours eu peur de tout ce qui se
passe je regarde partout je vois des
choses des fois blizzard jeux dans un
café je vois une une valve une valise un
truc à bordeaux n'est je vois tout de
suite je vois depuis une moto avec un
moteur qui tourne je regarde la fenêtre
j'entends du bruit gta sur la côte
d'azur il y avait le fameux feu
d'artifice il ya deux ans de ça j'ai moi
je le bruit ou faisait peur à bien si
j'ai dit va arriver quelque chose c'est
pas possible je vous jure que je n'avais
pas été chiffré c'est dans le restaurant
de ma soeur est bien beau frère et il ya
eu ce fameux enfin ce fameux camion qui
a été sur la foule et j'ai senti un
pressentiment
ah oui j'avais un pressentiment ce
jour-là qu'il allait avoir un quelque
chose avec ce feu d'artifice
et ça ça vraiment c'était j'étais là bas
encore sur la côte d'azur et vous avez
senti un truc un senti quelque chose qui
arrive ans était arrivé
jean-luc fait quoi aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je suis assez bon trois mois
j'ai pas repris le travail
je suis resté trois ans par dont on en
arrêt de maladie
j'ai pas pu reprendre le travail
j'ai été licencié pour inaptitude
trois ans après je me suis mis à part
l'emploi j'ai essayé de me défendre
c'était obligé de rester trois ans
encore sans rien faire sainté 6 ans et
aux jo il ya deux jours j'ai pris ma
retraite j'ai 69
jean-luc aujourd'hui vous vous sentez
vous considérez comme un com mais rien
je sais pas vous vous dites vous êtes
vous êtes un rescapé vous êtes un
franchement où vous avez eu de la chance
par rapport aux autres ou bien vous êtes
traumatisés vous n'arrivez plus à vivre
comme avant
je suis marqué à vie en cas est-ce que
je vous sens extrêmement triste
extrêmement marqué j'ai l'impression que
votre vie s'est arrêtée ce jour la
frange des voiliers à maison qui
m'attendait
mon ex belle mère parce que j'étais
divan c'est donc elle était présente là
on va faire à manger
j'avais préparé vendredi quoi parce que
je cuisine
j'avais préparé puis a laissé encore d
autres choses à préparer donc je n'avais
pas fait ils m'ont vu tout ça a été les
enfin bon du tout cependant ce sursaut
dans ce magasin tout le monde est
inquiet et il y avait deux jean-luc
nommé enfants croyez que j'étais puis la
saint-jean le cambodge dans le chaos
les indics avec une personne qui
s'appelait jean luc alphand j'étais
l'employée du magasin et donc qu'ils ont
ils ont ils ont dû prendre une équipe et
du trait aujourd'hui votre votre
quotidien autrichien il est il est
marqué par sa toute la 2d j'ai échappé
belle j'aurais pu y passer
il avait volé toujours peur qu'il y
avait une personne dans le client qui
voulait qu'ils voulaient essayer de
de maîtriser en fin de compte on a calmé
tout de suite parce que il gît là où ils
ont voulu faire qu il a une personne n'a
voulu faire un truc plus ton ami dans
ces acquéreurs parce que c'est la
question qu'on se pose tous c'est ce
qu'est une personne des personnes qui
ont décidé qu'ils se sont dit on va
essayer de sauver notre vie en essayant
de désarmer une perte terroristes une
personne comme monsieur qui avait à peu
près dans les 68 ans un fou sinon on
fait rien on tente rien tout ce qui vous
a dit vous a dit quoi il vous a dit j'ai
tenté quelque chose doit on donner à
plusieurs on voulait moment les
personnes en france et calmer parce
qu'il était prêt à tuer tout le monde
était déterminée et elle a vraiment pour
tuer quoi et puis voilà on peut pas même
si on est nombreux on peut pas faire au
départ l'affairé guy tellement il était
assez fait fort il était sûr armés ils
adorent ils avaient des explosifs et
avait même un taux d'explosifs nous a
montré à tout le monde
les gens qui étaient là on a essayé de
raisonner quand il a tué le petit à bout
portant
ce qu'il a pris l'armé d'essayer de tuer
le fils le duo hattab bien sûr été
quelque chose sous sol qui a essayé de
tenter quelque chose leur la vue je suis
descendu je n'ai pas vu pourtant je suis
descendu mais j'ai pas vu je sais pas où
il était caché jupe monter deux
personnes qui n'étaient pas cachés jordi
montée je vais forcer à monter
ils sont montés m'ont suivi et puis là à
ce moment là ils sont mis avec les
autres